warnings of a border surge be downed
president biden is plowing full speed
ahead with the end of the title 42
just four days from now even most
republicans and democrats warn it will
unleash a tidal wave of migrants border
apprehension sending a new record in
april with 234 thousand migrant
encounters ron desantis thinks the
mexican drug cartels should be awarding
joe biden
biden should be given an honorary
membership in the mexican drug cartels
because nobody has done more to help the
cartels than biden with his open border
policies and so so it's a total disaster
uh it's been a disaster i fear with
title 42 if they do repeal it i think
things are fixing to get even worse and
the head of dhs is finally admitting
that ending title 42 will bring a
migrant surge to border towns
we recognize that with the end of title
42 there very well may be an increased
surge in migration and we have to equip
them with the resources and capabilities
to address that increase as well
katie i want to go to you so i'm
conflicted on this i i understand why
people are advocating especially people
in congress that don't like to be blamed
or take responsibility for things are
advocating to keep title 42 but if the
nature of title 42 is truly about
coronavirus and public health i mean i
don't think you should be using a
band-aid to fix a tourniquet problem as
a guy who's needed tourniquets before i
mean how do you feel about this well i
don't want to talk about tourniquets
because i'll pass out if i keep talking
about that but uh i agree with you in
the sense that if they're going to say
that title 42 is a public health measure
then the president has other tools
within the department of homeland
security and the executive branch to
stop this problem they're throwing their
hands up and acting like well a judge
says that we have to take title 42 off
and therefore we have no other options
that's not true but this administration
has taken the stance that they have
turned
ice into a transportation agency they've
turned border patrol into a processing
agency and they have absolutely
emboldened cartels they're making a
hundred million dollars a week a week
just on human smuggling alone we just
had uh overdoses more than 100 000
americans last year that's a direct
result of this problem and it's not that
these people are just going to border
towns as if that's somehow acceptable
they're getting flown on the taxpayer
dime by the federal government to cities
and towns all across the country and
they're essentially the administration
is you know finishing the last leg of
the trafficking or smuggling process and
i've been saying that for years it's
clear they don't want to change it
they're not going to change it and
americans will suffer as a result
dana do you think if we built a wall we
would we would have a handle on this
well not completely yeah i think it
could help right but i think
walls work in many places and
unfortunately
the bright administration has said not
to do it here's my perspective on this
from my understanding nancy pelosi and
donald trump were working on a deal that
would allow for daca i think it was
going to reform visas or double or
triple visas donald trump offered her
the majority of what democrats asked for
in exchange for the wall if the
democrats biggest argument is a wall
don't work the wall don't work well i am
from georgia
if their biggest argument is a wall
doesn't work what's the risk in letting
trump have the wall in that deal from
what four years ago and where would we
be today well because joey you know that
there i long believe that they would
rather have a problem
to
basically do politics off of than to
solve it and
i think that the wall i guess to some
other uh their left-wing base was just
so offensive they couldn't possibly do
it
jesse it was just about not letting
trump have a win wasn't it it was and it
was also about getting the migrants into
the country at a certain point where
it's not politically suicidal they don't
mind the waves they just don't like it
when it hurts their poll numbers yeah
and it's going to hurt their poll
numbers so badly when you see these
images because the mainstream media is
going to have to cover this they can't
hide you're going to see these harrowing
images hear these horrible stories and
you're going to get reports from these
border towns of these cities being
overwhelmed and at a time when the
country's already overwhelmed with gas
prices and inflation you can't just
surge a quarter million new people a
month into these small municipalities
it's just not physically possible to do
that and so you get rid of title 42 they
just broke the record in april almost a
quarter million illegal border crossers
they repelled about 90 000 over
title 42. now those 90 000 get to stay
so they're not going to be
kicking anybody out of the country a
quarter million a month for as long as
possible and then since they're not
doing any deportations you're basically
getting a million illegal aliens into
the country every four months unchecked
with no plan to do anything about it and
jessica like i haven't touched on
fentanyl because i think that's a
different issue and it's worthy of its
of its own segment we're talking about
immigration broadly not only have the
numbers hit record highs but you know
what's going down families and kids and
you know what's going up single males so
there it seems like the writing is
pretty easy to read on the wall why the
democrats really think republicans just
don't want brown people here i mean
obviously there's a lot more to it than
that obviously there's a lot more to it
than that and some democrats think that
they just don't want brown people here
and when people are talking about you
know that everyone who's coming over
it's ms-13 and blah blah that's how you
get to that point where you're having
the discussion right dana's coming over
and ukraine
part of the resiliency
everyone's here part of the problem is
that this crisis is going on while the
ukrainian crisis is going on and we do
want to make sure the country feels very
comfortable with ukrainian refugees
coming over here and that's muddying up
the issue but to dana's point
every administration has a border
problem and republicans and democrats
both don't want to solve this we've had
gang of eight bills that have been
wildly popular democrats have supported
presidency
well
he didn't put together
platforms he certainly did build the
wall bad hombres i heard all of it and
he didn't put together a coalition that
was going to be able to get this done
the gang of eight did do that and the
fact is is that every single
person in a position of power
politically speaking benefits in some
way from undocumented labor and they go
to states like florida they go up to
oregon they pick grapes in
in wine season picking oranges whatever
it is and taking a lot of the jobs that
americans do not want to do for wages
that americans will not stand for and we
all at this table agree that by and
large people who are here and yes they
crossed illegally are good people
who want to pay into the system if
they're afforded that opportunity and
many of them are well listen i grew up
in the town of 78 hispanic inside the
city there are a lot of really good
people that want to be here but they're
not served coming here and living in the
shadows and that's the problem and
you're right both parties create a
pathway to citizenship for them and let
them come out of the shadows
all right well that's your that's your
solution there you go all right up next
elon musk ready to ride the big red wave
as the billionaire bashes democrats hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now